- I rather you just
keep massaging my knee,
instead of of just (bleep) me
over, and pulling my hair out.
- No.
(upbeat rock music)
- Mikey.
- Reese.
- I'm Phil.
- I'm Mark.
- Mark?
- Alright.
- I will enjoy taking the
hairs off of your legs.
- I hope, uh--
- Denning.
- Denning. I hope Denning's kind to me.
- The nerves are slowly building.
- Well, I haven't had my legs waxed before
and I never really planned to.
- But, we're about to
change that, aren't we?
(rock music)
- Take out a double wax strip
and rub it in between your hands.
- Dude, this is not
coming off easy at all.
- Very romantic.
- Mmm.
- And now, you rub my leg.
- Grab, you already know, just do it.
- The instructions
clearly state, "Be brave.
"The faster you pull,--
- Be brave.
- "the more hair you'll remove."
So, you ready? You brave?
- Uhh, okay, ready?
- One, two,
(hair rips off)
- (yells) Shit!
- (groans)
(hair rips off)
- (moans)
Ooh, that sounded like it hurt.
(hair rips off)
- (exhales)
- [Reese] Do you need to go up?
That way?
- That's along the grain
of the hair.
- Oh, I was going up with you.
- That's probably why it
so (bleep) hurt so much.
- (laughs)
(hair rips off)
- (groans)
- You know that hurt significantly more
than the first time.
- Mother (bleep) that hurt! Ooh.
- Ah, (exhales) that was really painful.
- What is this?
- Uh--
- That's like landing strip.
- Yeah the landing strip, yeah.
- Like I just had a Brazilian.
- People pay extra for that.
(hair rips off)
- (shudders)
- Nah, shit!
(hair rips off)
- [Voiceover] Whatcha!
- Mother (bleep).
(hair rips off)
- (groans)
- There's no way girls do that.
They do laser now, they
don't do waxing. That's--
- Why would you not just shave your legs?
- [Mark] I didn't know
my legs were that hairy.
- [Phil] You could frame this,
and it could be like
a piece of modern art.
(upbeat rock music)
- Waxing a stranger's legs
was probably a lot easier
than waxing someone you know,
because you don't have that
trust that can be lost.
- That wasn't as bad as
I thought it would be.
- Yeah, yeah. I have an
appreciation, I guess, yeah.
- I'm feeling very different, like smooth.
- I must say that my leg
is still full of Andy's
beard muttons, though.
- I'm gonna have to wear
jeans for the next few months.
- Like as far as whether
or not I like this look,
I think I might. I might keep
it around to see how it works.
You know? I'll still test
it out, experiment with it.
- Never doing this again!
Nah, it's done. Done.